please welcome jermaine fowler to the
show
hey what's up thanks for having me oh
jermaine
i'm so excited that you're here oh thank
you i am too i just watched wedding
singer the other night
so this is really cool i love you very
much drew so
thank you for saying that and i was
looking up your body of work
and now you're on the cover of essence
magazine and
talking about blowing up this thing is
making such
waves i mean there you are with eddie
and arsenio
front and center yo
they didn't tell me they were going to
be aligning it that way i had no idea i
thought i was probably going to they're
going to get my shoulder or at least
at least my cheek bone i don't know
something small but not like my whole
body
like in the middle of two of my favorite
comedians so
that's just wild like it is wild when i
first saw it
uh cried cried um
it was uh still when i think about it
it's still kind of you know
it's and it's it means a lot you know um
eddie's my idol
um arsenio is one of the greatest ever
you know um i truly appreciate both of
them um for being so welcoming and
inviting me on that set and let me do my
thing and i mean you're stepping into
coming to
america this beloved film
and like was it true you were in diapers
when you first saw it
yeah i was about one month when the
movie came out um
and i first saw it when i was eight
because it was just playing in my house
ever since i was a kid and i finally got
to sneak in and watch it and i watched
it and
and then he laughed it just has so many
these moments are super funny but also
super
deep and um truly connect you know uh uh
you to the to the characters man um
everybody
james jones man you know like you don't
get an all-star cast like that
ever and eddie eddie pulled it off and
it's just it's it's top you know one of
the top movies ever made and uh
i just it holds such a special place in
my heart so
this whole opportunity just it means
everything i got to do saturday night
live with
eddie um when i was seven years old in
1982
and you know and then eddie murphy was
just there he then did the beverly hills
cops and
you know just one hit after another um
including coming to america where i
found myself saying on a daily basis
i have a date with lisa
and he swears he did not say it that way
but i
hear it that way and he was kind enough
to indulge me
and then i also sing on a daily basis to
my own daughters
she's your queen
it's an everyday song for me i actually
sing it a lot in honor of my
daughters because they're my queens but
can you tell us about the queen's
like close to your heart uh i would love
to
um i'd be honored to actually um uh
my mom uh marcia she's right here uh
that is
um she's
my everything and then you got um
got my grandma um dolores i named my
production company after her
um and you know then you got my partner
my girlfriend uh megan
um she's i couldn't raise
our kids without her and i love her to
death um
those those are my queens uh and my
little princess to bay
uh you know she's not a queen yet but
she she bout to be
she about to be a queen and um i i just
love them i
i wouldn't be here without any of them i
love them death
i appreciate everything i've ever done
for you i'm glad that i
acknowledged your level of appreciation
earlier when you were speaking of eddie
and arsenio and just
everything that's happening in your life
because it's there
and it's palpable and you're amazing and
your daughter
is lucky to have you in her life i'm
sorry
no i i just i'm so glad the way that you
appreciate
the people in your life and uh
all last week we highlighted um some
real life queens who are going above and
beyond to
serve their communities and jermaine
would you be up for surprising them with
me
oh yeah i would love to okay
all right um i have a clip of our uh
royal queens here take a look
after experiencing homelessness first
hand we are helping women experiencing
homelessness within washington state
and we're on our way to be nationwide
dc femtech's mission is to support those
women
here who are in tech growing their
career whether they're designers data
scientists
programmers and to celebrate amazing
women in technology
through our dc femtech awards at she's
the first
we work with local organizations all
around the world
to ensure that girls are educated
respected and heard
we support young people who are actively
following their dreams and need
mentorship or just
a helping hand the little pantry has
about 250 to 300 families
who come to us for groceries every
single saturday
whatever a person needs if we can do it
we should do it
please welcome nicki shayna erica stacy
tammy and kristen to the show
thank you um i am just
so in awe of all the work you are doing
and
um i'm actually here with someone who
wants to celebrate you
as well uh say hi to one of these stars
of coming to america jermaine fowler
congratulations thank you
thank you you're welcome y'all deserve
it uh it's very motivating and inspiring
to see what y'all have done
i truly appreciate it thank you all so
much thank you thank you this is
beautiful
thank you and we have been celebrating
you
all week and um our hearts
are are with you our inspiration is
insurmountable because of what you're
doing and
amazon too was inspired by each one of
your stories and
they wanted to donate a 500 amazon
gift card to each of you to thank you
for all that you do
but that's not all amazon will also be
delivering smiles
and donating ten thousand dollars to
each of your organizations
to help you continue to do the
incredible work that you are
doing in your communities thank you
thank you thank you so much
thank you thank you queen and also
amazon thank you for uh bringing
a classic uh in its new iteration coming
to america right when we need it the
most
and i have to say jermaine you're so
incredible in it
really and truly thank you thank you so
much
it's also available to stream globally
as
of march 5th on amazon prime video
go and stream it right now thank you
wonderful women thank you jermaine